Captain Francis Pike leads his team across
the arctic tundra.
In the distance, they can see the city of
Audapaupadopolis.
It floats 7.8 kilometers above the ground
and is filled with mysteries and treasures
beyond even the Foundation’s wildest dreams.
It is September of 1933 when the SCP Foundation
first catches wind of something odd going
on in the arctic.
A British airman named Sir George Dansen flies
over the North Sea heading to Norway.
After he lands in Oslo, Dansen begins ranting
about a floating city.
The Foundation immediately disseminates contradictory
information and manipulates the story to include
that Dansen had been drinking during his flight,
so everything he is saying is probably the
result of a drunken hallucination.
While SCP agents spread lies, the Foundation
immediately launches an investigation.
The team that is sent to the arctic confirms
what Dansen claims to have seen.
There is indeed a floating city there.
Now Captain Pike and his team stare at the
island in the sky as their hot-air balloons
are filled behind them.
The arctic wind whips up small snow tornadoes
as the temperature plummets.
The balloons are ready, and Pike orders his
men to board.
They lift off from the ground and pull their
parka hoods over their heads to protect them
from the arctic blasts at high altitudes.
Pike and his team slowly drift over the city
of Audapaupadopolis.
When they are somewhat in the middle of the
floating island, the hot-air balloons are
lowered and the team lands without incident.
To their surprise, the exploratory team finds
that the floating city has its own micro-climate,
which is much more pleasant than the frigid
arctic.
They remove their winter gear.
“Proceed with caution,” Pike tells his
men.
“We have no idea what we’re going to find
in the city.”
The architecture is clearly old, but not exactly
like anything on Earth today.
It seems to be a conglomerate of ancient Mesopotamian
design mixed with the design features of several
other cultures.
Many of the buildings that line the stone
streets are crumbling and the city overall
is in ruins.
Pike leads his team down a series of roads.
Scientists photograph and take notes on the
city for Foundation records.
SCP agents check around every corner to make
sure there is nothing hiding in the shadows.
The team comes to a crossroads.
“Halt!”
Pike shouts.
Standing in front of them is an old man with
long grey hair and a white beard.
He seems to be of Middle Eastern descent.
“Hello friends!”
the old man says.
“Welcome to Audapaupadopolis.
I am the caretaker of the city.
I have been expecting you.
Please follow me.”
The old man turns around and proceeds down
the causeway.
Pike hesitates for a moment.
“Stay alert,” he whispers to the agents
behind him.
Then he begins to follow the old man down
the street.
As Pike walks he takes in the grandeur that
the city once held.
The roads are as wide as the main avenues
back in London, while the buildings, although
in shambles, still retain some of their ancient
beauty.
Pike begins to walk a little faster to catch
up with the old man.
“What happened here?” he asks.
The man turns his head.
“All will be revealed soon Francis Pike;
just be patient.”
“How do you know my name?” asks Pike.
The old man smiles.
They turn another corner and in front of them
is the Grand Hall.
It seems to have survived whatever catastrophe
befell the rest of the city.
Pike stops and stares up at the massive structure
with his mouth ajar.
“Come,” says the old man as he motions
the SCP team to follow him up the steps into
the main hall.
“Let’s eat.”
The old man prepares a simple meal, but one
that fills the stomachs and satisfies Pike
and his men.
At the conclusion of the meal, Captain Pike
approaches the mysterious man.
“I feel like you deserve an explanation
as to who we are and why we’re here,”
Pike says.
The old man raises his hand.
“You are from the Foundation,” he replies.
“I already know all about the Foundation
and you Francis Pike.
I have been waiting for you to arrive for
a long time.
There are things I need to show you in the
city.
There are old secrets and ancient relics from
the past that you were sent here to learn
about.”
Pike looks at the man and squints.
“What are you talking about?
How could you know we were coming?
And what relics are you referring to exactly?”
The old man grins and places a hand on Captain
Pike’s shoulder.
Pike feels a longing emotion well up inside
of him.
It’s as if he has been waiting for this
moment his whole life.
“Come,” says the old man.
“You and your men need rest.”
He shows Pike and the exploration team to
several rooms down the hallway where they
can set up for the night.
The rooms are large and comfortable.
“Sleep well Francis Pike, tomorrow I have
much to show you.”
The old man leaves the room and proceeds down
the hallway to his small, humble, chamber.
The next morning Pike and the other SCP agents
are greeted by the rising sun and the old
man waiting for them on the steps of the Grand
Hall.
He leads them through the city.
“There are three temples I wish to show
you,” the old man says to Pike.
“You will notice that their architecture
and imagery differ from most of the other
structures in the city.
Make sure you listen very carefully Francis
Pike, as what you're about to learn could
save the universe…
or perhaps destroy it.”
Pike is speechless.
All he can do is nod his head.
The old man leads the SCP agents to the middle
of the city where the three temples reside.
Each one has its own unique iconography and
style.
The art seems to reflect important events
in history or subjects that hold significance
in the past.
The old man proceeds to walk towards the first
temple.
Upon entering the structure there is a mural
of two naked people watching the horizon from
a treeline.
Behind them are a wolf and bear that seem
to be protectively standing guard.
Directly opposite of this picture is a painting
of a figure holding a flaming sword on a hill.
As Pike and his team enter the main hall they
are welcomed by a gigantic mural depicting
the sun rising over Audapaupadopolis.
“This is where the Temple of Sunrise gets
its name,” the old man says gesturing to
the mural on the far wall.
Below the sunrise is a golden man holding
a spear with a silver point.
He wears a shining crown.
Pike can’t help but notice that the man
in the mural looks similar to their guide,
just a lot younger.
Perhaps it is his son or a relative, Pike
thinks to himself.
Above the sunrise is a dragon with green eyes.
Engraved across the dragon’s body are the
words “THEY WILL KNOW WHAT IS”.
The other walls contain images of the same
golden man.
In one picture he stands at the foot of a
throne with a naked woman wrapped in snakes
beside him.
On another, the golden man sits on the throne
with an iron crown hovering above his head.
Behind him are monoliths of five figures.
One is made of gears and steel, another is
made of flesh and blood, the third is made
of ice and stone, the fourth is made of stars,
and the final is made of eyes.
The SCP agents in the room begin to buzz with
excitement.
They start recording everything they see.
“We must continue on,” the old man says.
“There isn’t much time left.”
Pike nods and orders a small team to stay
behind to continue documenting the Temple
of Sunrise.
The next building they enter is the Temple
of Sunset.
Within its walls are maps of different towns
and landscapes.
One of the maps is of Audapaupadopolis itself.
The words “THE LANDS OF MEN” are scrolled
over the map in the entry hall.
The old man stops at the opening to the main
gallery.
“Prepare yourself Francis Pike.
What you are about to witness will not be
pleasant.”
They head into the next room where the temperature
immediately shoots up.
“What the hell is producing all of that
heat?”
Pike asks.
There is nothing but crumbling walls and fallen
columns visible in the room.
One of the scientists hollers from the back
of the group.
“Jesus!
Sir, I think you need to take a look at this.”
He walks up to Pike and hands him a pair of
thermal imaging goggles.
Pike puts them on.
“Damn,” Pike mutters.
With the thermal lenses on he can now see
a massive humanoid entity lying dead on the
floor.
His body is so large that it covers the murals
on three of the walls.
Pike notices that the temperature in the room
is still continuing to increase as if the
dead giant is radiating heat.
The Foundation classifies the entity as SCP-4840-B.
It has six arms and six legs each connected
by metal chains to iron flails at the end.
A sigil has been brandished into the middle
of the entity’s chest.
“What is that?”
Pike asks.
The old man just shakes his head.
“One of the many who have fallen,” he
responds.
The old man points to the only wall that is
not blocked by the massive body of SCP-4840-B
and frowns.
The golden man is depicted here as well.
Pike can’t help but feel there is some sort
of connection between Audapaupadopolis, the
old man, and the golden figure he keeps seeing
in the murals.
In the Temple of Sunset the golden man sits
atop a white horse with his iron crown resting
on his head.
Behind him is a massive army of men and women
holding axes and swords.
Across from the golden man and his army are
legions of green and grey figures with six
eyes dressed in brilliantly colored clothing.
An intense lightning storm appears to be amassing
in the distance.
Captain Pike looks up at the ceiling to see
it covered in stars, however, he does not
recognize any of the constellations.
“Is the golden man I keep seeing y—”
but before Pike can finish his question, the
old man cuts him off.
“We must keep going.”
He turns and exits the temple.
Pike does not want to push the old man; he
seems to be a wealth of knowledge and the
only way to learn more about Audapaupadopolis
and what it all means.
They exit the Temple of Sunset and continue
to the final structure in the middle of the
city.
The old man leads Pike and the rest of the
SCP agents to the smallest temple of the three.
He stops just outside of the doorway.
“This is the Temple of Night,” he proclaims.
“What you see on the surface is deceiving.
This temple goes deep underground.
It contains a labyrinth of passages that one
could get lost in forever, so please be careful.”
“Aren’t you coming?”
Pike asks.
“No,” responds the old man.
“I do not enter the Temple of Night…
I have my reasons, which do not concern you.”
Pike nods and then signals his men to follow
him into the temple.
He notices that many of the murals in the
passageways and rooms of the Temple of Night
depict the same image of a massive tree in
the middle of a vast forest.
In each instance of the tree, there seem to
be red lights surrounding the base, human-like
figures hanging from its branches, and structures
wrapped in vines surrounding the trunk.
The hallways are illuminated by some unknown
light source.
It is as if torches line the walls and give
off a dull yellowish glow, but there is no
fire to be seen.
Embedded in the walls are sarcophagi with
intricate carvings in their stone casings.
Pike can’t help but notice scratching sounds
coming from within the sarcophagi as if someone,
or something, is trying to claw its way out.
The exploration team reaches the innermost
chamber of the temple.
There is a staircase in the middle of the
room that descends below the floor.
However, its entrance is covered by rubble
from a collapsed wall.
Suddenly an SCP agent runs up to Captain Pike.
“Sir, I think you should see this.”
Pike follows the man back through a series
of twists and turns.
He stops at a closed door.
The Foundation seal is carved into the wood.
It seems as if the carving has been there
for a long time, which is impossible since
they are the first SCP team to explore the
city of Audapaupadopolis.
The agent pushes open the door and Pike steps
in.
He is astonished by what he finds.
It seems he has been transported to an abandoned
Foundation site.
All of the lights are off, but he can tell
that it is some kind of central command center
due to the screens and setup of the space.
Painted in black block letters on one of the
walls is: Site-00-00-00.
Pike quickly exits back through the entranceway
and shuts the door behind him.
He looks at the SCP agent who brought him
to the room.
“Secure this door and make sure no one goes
in… or comes out.
Do I make myself clear?”
Pike orders his men to exit the temple.
After everyone is out, Captain Pike walks
over to the old man who is sitting on the
steps outside.
“Did you find what you were looking for
Francis Pike?”
the old man asks.
Captain Pike shakes his head.
He stares down, eyes wide, at the stone steps
of the temple.
“I see,” says the old man.
“I have something else to show you Francis
Pike.”
The old man leads Pike back to the Grand Hall
that they had slept in the night before.
He brings him through a series of passageways
and down a staircase.
They stop in front of a large door.
“Open it,” the old man whispers.
Captain Francis Pike walks up to the door
and pushes it open.
On the other side is endless darkness from
which he hears his own voice speaking to him
through the ether.
Pike begins to walk towards the darkness.
The old man places his hand on Pike’s shoulder
and pulls him back.
Then he shuts the door.
“The light of the world has long since left
that place, and mortal men can no longer walk
it,” says the old man.
“I needed to show it to you as a warning.
Things are not always what they seem Francis
Pike.”
That night Pike lies awake staring at the
ceiling of the Grand Hall thinking about the
old man.
He sits up and begins jotting down his thoughts.
In his official report, he identifies the
old man as SCP-4840-A, but in his journal,
he can’t help but refer to him as a friend.
There is something about the old man, something
special.
Pike knows there is much more to his story,
and the story of the Flying City of Audapaupadopolis.
Now watch “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The
Full Story Compilation (SCP Animation).”
Or check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation (SCP Animation).”